hello
my name is dr jen peckel i'm an
assistant professor in the department of
entomology at michigan state university
i would first like to thank the
organizers for developing this virtual
event on forensic sciences
i am fascinated by the whos whys and
hows of
insect and microbial dynamics during
decomposition
specifically how this basic information
can ultimately be used in real world
situations
today i will provide a brief primer on
the postmortem microbiome
and discuss some of the research
activities i've been part of for over a
decade
i would like to note there will be an
image of a body in this presentation
however it will not be a full body and
it will only be
brief in its presentation
we know that the microbiome for the
microbes and their associated genes
are vital for living organisms many
consortia
such as those listed on the screen such
as the human microbiome
project the american gut the microbe net
the interdisciplinary microbiome project
the cardio biome
and the microbiome center just to name a
few
are focused on identifying the microbial
communities
and their roles within a framework of
topographical diversity
geographic diversity and impact on host
lifestyle
there has been great interest in the
factors which affect microbial community
structure and function with much
attention on the role of host diet
and the specific components of diet on
human health
along these lines microbial communities
are key to achieving a better
understanding of risk factors
prevention treatment and spread that are
all
associated with various disease dynamics
a natural avenue to expand the knowledge
of the living host microbiome
is to assess how these microbial
communities change after death
and determine if and how this
information could be beneficial for
forensic applications
first before we get into the
applications of the postmortem
microbiome for forensics
let's take a step back and talk about
how the microbiome after death
is fundamentally an ecological question
the necrobiome is defined as the
community of organisms
associated with necromass decomposition
and includes their interactions with the
necromass with each other
and with the surrounding habitat and
ecosystem
this concept applies across a wide array
of decomposing organic materials
including but not limited to plant
fungal
dung or frass or animal necromast types
and can occur in both aquatic and
terrestrial realms
as decay progresses the organic matter
and associated activities of the
microbes facilitate the attraction of
invertebrate and vertebrate
saprophages that directly consume the
necromass
and the microbial communities
critically all of these aspects of the
microbiome are interlinked
and the relative importance of each
component of the necrobiome
and their function will depend on the
intrinsic qualities of decaying
necromass
and the extrinsic controlling
environmental factors such as
temperature
and humidity
there are numerous organisms that are
associated with the necrobiome such as
the microbes
insects and vertebrate scavengers but
for the purposes of this presentation
i will focus only on the microbial
activity that is occurring
after host death
there are three main questions that may
come to mind when considering the human
postmortem microbiome
one what is it two
why do we study it and three
how do we study it
to answer the what is it the postmortem
microbiome
is an emerging field in forensic science
with broad application for death
investigation
think about time since death essentially
it is assessing and determining the
dynamics of the microbiome
after host death in this instance after
human death
why do we study it while the foundation
of forensic microbiology
began in the early 2000s resulting from
bioterrorism threats
the expansion of using the entire
microbial communities
so the microbial organisms their genes
and their gene functions
in a forensic context began in the early
2010s
by better understanding the postmortem
microbial dynamics
we will be able to use that information
and incorporate it
into the techniques that are routinely
used during death investigation
such as ballistics such as trace
evidence
and becoming more routinely used your
digital footprint
also the human postmortem microbiome can
be important
in the context of public health it is an
opportunity for practitioners to be able
to identify
public health concerns such as
meningitis
legionnaires or even coven 19.
the next question is how do we study the
postmortem microbiome
at its simplest we're trying to identify
what microbes are present when are they
present
how abundant are they and what is their
function
these questions can typically be
answered by relying on a handful
of molecular biomarkers that aid in
determining the species that are present
in a community at any given time how
these communities change over time
or environmental conditions and what
their function may be there are
different microbial targets
that are most often used for forensic
purposes
to identify the consortium of microbes
present
this includes amplicon-based sequencing
including the 16s marker for bacteria
and archaea
the its marker for fungi and the ats
marker for micro eukaryotes
but there is currently a push towards
whole genome sequencing for these
complex microbiological samples
which may yield greater microbial
resolution increased accuracy of their
relative abundance
and allow identification of more
bacteria archaea
viruses and eukaryotes additionally
this technology can be used for
assessments of putative functional genes
there has been an interest in
post-mortem microbiomes for forensic
applications
for at least the past 10 years
foundational work began with using
surrogate animal models
primarily swine and mouse carcasses for
characterizing the microbes present
after death
and identifying if a predictable
succession pattern would occur
that could help identify how long that
host animal
had been dead the next step was to use
human bodies
for postmortem microbiome studies
initially
these projects were conducted at
anthropological research facilities
which use donor bodies
excellent work on long-term
decomposition and successional patterns
resulted from these studies and continue
to provide
very useful information
for example successional data can
provide information
about which bacteria are present at what
time
these successional data are important
because they in essence provide a
microbiological clock
for the time since death these long-term
successional studies can go out months
or even years in some instances
having these types of data is important
for forensic practitioners
to narrow down the estimated time range
of death
however the use of human donors at
anthropological facilities has its
limitations
typically there are small sample sizes
due to space limitations
and also the donors are from a selected
group of individuals
and thus may not be representative of
the population
some research groups have incorporated a
survey-based approach
that will use swabs collected during
routine case work
to create a database of human postmortem
microbiomes
the use of collecting samples from
routine casework is exciting because
you have sample opportunities from a
wide swath of the population
and a variety of death circumstances
however the limitations to routine case
work is that you
only are able to sample one body at one
point in time
thus you do not have successional data
on any given body
you can see on the screen there are lots
of different publications that have
resulted from these various approaches
for identifying the dynamics of the
human postmortem microbiome
first i'll talk about how these
postmortem microbial collections are
made
trained personnel at a collaborating
medical examiner's office
collects these samples on a routine
basis
this means that a predetermined number
of body sites
are swagged with individual sterile
cotton tip swabs
the individual swab that's associated
with each body part
is then stored at -20 until further
processing
we have up to 10 different body sites
per case
and the number of swabs that are
collected per case depends on the
circumstances of death
for example some bodies received to the
medical examiner's office
may not have all body sites available
for microbial collections
this means that we will collect as many
microbial samples as possible
but ideally we would like to have all 10
body sites collected
per case additionally
for each of the cases we collect the
following metadata
this type of information is beneficial
because it helps us to develop
models of how we can use the postmortem
microbiome
to identify the time sense death perhaps
the cause and manner of death
and even where an individual may have
died
as you can see on the screen these
metadata covariates are typical of the
information
that's collected during routine death
investigation
this includes data such as the case
number sex
race the date of birth the decedent's
residence
the event location of where the death
occurred the time
and date pronounced dead any additional
notes that may be important based on the
scene
the decomposition description the
estimated postmortem interval or pmi
information regarding the height weight
bmi
and then of course the manner and cause
of death
once these swab samples are in the lab
each individual swab
undergoes a series of steps that
ultimately allows us to identify the
microbiome
this includes taking an individual swab
extracting and quantifying the dna
we then send that dna to a core facility
that specializes
in processing and sequencing dna to
identify
what species are in that sample and what
their function may be
currently high throughput sequencing
technologies are used to obtain
all of the genetic information found
within the biomarkers of interest for
any given sample
in this example i was most interested in
what the 16s
rrna region was because that helps us to
identify
the bacterial and archaea that are
present in each sample
the sequence information is then
processed by bioinformatic and
statistical pipelines to provide an
overview of the microbial communities
and this pipeline may include different
outputs
such as species richness diversity
relative abundance and other
common ecological metrics all of these
data
are then visualized and statistical
analysis are performed
to identify if there are any microbial
communities that are associated with
specific questions we have regarding the
death investigation
now i would like to talk about the
results from a large scale survey
of the human postmortem microbiome that
was conducted
in collaboration with the wayne county
medical examiner's office
this office is located in detroit
michigan so in the southeast region of
the state
in collaboration with the chief medical
examiner dr carl schmidt
we were able to collect swab samples
during routine death investigation
from 188 cases
the demographic of these 188 cases
spanned
sex race age manner of death and cause
of death
i would like to note that all of the
samples collected were from adults
meaning individuals aged 18 or older
different microbial swabs were collected
from different body sites
and the microbial communities were
processed using the previously mentioned
pipelines to result
in some very interesting data
this study was the first of its kind to
employ a large-scale survey
that means the 188 cases were by far the
largest number of cases that had been
used
to identify the human postmortem
microbiome
previous work using the human postmortem
microbiome
had a sample size of less than 50 cases
so ours was almost three times larger
than any of the previously reported data
our data resulted in some interesting
trends
the first question we were interested in
answering using data from the human
postmortem microbiome
was are the microbial communities
different based on the body site
we know in living human hosts each body
site
has its own unique resident of microbial
taxa
it seems simplistic but whether or not
this distinction of microbial
communities
based on the body site persisted after
death was an important question
the first way we analyze those data is
through the use of a principal
coordinates analysis plot which you can
see on the left
the easiest way to interpret a pcoa plot
is by looking at the dots
and their relative position to each
other each of those dots
represents the microbial community from
an individual swab sample
the closer the dots are together means
the microbial communities are more
similar to one another
and the farther the dots are from each
other indicates that the microbial
communities are dissimilar
for this particular data visualization
we were interested in five different
sites on the body
this included the eyes nose ears
mouth and rectum the eyes are the green
triangles
the nose are the blue hexagons the ears
are the dark blue diamonds
the mouth are the purple squares and the
rectum are the red diamonds
based on this pcoa it is clear that the
microbial communities are structured
based on body site we see there is a
clear distinction of the rectal samples
the ear samples and also the mouth
samples
now looking at the right side of the
screen this is an alpha diversity plot
based on the phylogenetic distance of
the different microbial communities that
were present in the samples
on the left column these are all the
samples separated out by body site
that are less than 48 hours post-mortem
the right column indicates that the
samples were collected
after an estimated postmortem interval
of 49 hours
what's interesting to see is that in the
ears
nose eyes and mouth there is a
decrease in diversity that occurs after
that two day mark
this trend is not seen in the rectal
samples so we know that those
communities are more stable for longer
periods of time after death
also based on these swabs we used
predictive and silico
functional analysis this means the
nucleotide sequences
identified in each of the samples were
run through
a separate bioinformatic pipeline to
identify the potential
function of the different sequences
for this heat map the columns represent
the different body sites
and their predicted functional profiles
the brighter yellow colors signifies an
increased detection
in function after 48 hours post-mortem
essentially we're seeing an increase in
this activity approximately two days
after death
based on these results it was very
interesting to identify
that after 48 hours there was an
increase in activity of bacterial
chemotaxis
bacterial motility proteins and also
flagellar assembly
we hypothesized that the increase in
activity from these results
was indicative of the bacterial being
allowed to proliferate
and spread throughout the body because
there was no longer an influence of the
host immune system
keeping that bacterial proliferation in
check
samples collected from the large scale
survey were also
used in antibiotic resistance gene
detection
my colleague dr heather jordan at
mississippi state university
used several different assays across 34
samples
to identify if there were specific
antibiotic resistance genes
these results were surprising because
almost 60 percent of all of the samples
had antibiotic resistance genes detected
using whole genome shotgun sequencing
this antibiotic resistance was confirmed
also through the use of a commercially
available qpcr kit
that was specifically focused on
antibiotic resistance genes
additionally using these data we
collaborated with a public health
geographer
here at michigan state university dr
amber pearson
the focus of this project was to
identify how the human postmortem
microbiome
correlated with the neighborhood blight
and greening efforts that are occurring
throughout the city of detroit
based on these analysis we were able to
identify positive correlations
between light and greening efforts and
particular bacteria of interest
specifically blight had a positive
correlation with potential pathogenic
bacteria such as clostridium species
while green remediation had positive
correlations with potential commensals
such as lactobacillus
i'm excited to continue these different
types of collaborations to further
enhance the knowledge of the human
postmortem microbiome
as of today we have a database of human
postmortem microbiome samples at
michigan state university
this database began in 2014 and
currently we have over 3 000 cases
over 15 000 individual swabs and we have
four different countries that are
participating in the collection process
of the human postmortem microbiome
while we have a lot of samples and
continued to collect we've only
scratched the surface
on the total number of cases and the
total number of
swabs that have been processed and put
through these pipelines to identify the
microbiome
i've recently been awarded funding from
the national institute of justice
that will help us dig deeper into this
postmortem database
in collaboration with dr schmidt dr
jordan and dr eric benbow at michigan
state university
we are excited to move forward on
exploring new microbiome data
from these samples one question that may
seem simple but is very important is how
do we analyze all of these big data in a
forensic context
there are several open source
bioinformatic pipelines that are
available
that are routinely used in human
microbiome projects
the question is how well do those
bioinformatic pipelines work for
forensic applications
and the postmortem microbiome
first the data are run through some
common bioinformatic pipelines
then there are questions answered such
as do we verify the data
do we normalize the data do we keep all
of the raw data
and then we compare the outputs that are
produced by these pipelines to see how
similar or dissimilar the results may be
the results from these analysis comes
from the work of excellent graduate
students
after going through all of the steps
you're left with millions
of reads how do you find useful
information within those millions of
reads
well you look at big data and how it can
be useful in forensics
for one example we can take all of the
sequences that were found in those 188
cases
and identify if there are different body
areas that are going to be most
informative
for answering the questions of when did
a person die
how did they die and where did they die
evaluation and analysis of these data
continues to be ongoing
this results in part because software
continues to be developed
that is more specific to answering the
questions of interest related to
microbiome data
also computational capacity is becoming
much more powerful
more time efficient and less expensive
thus
we may be able to generate larger data
sets and ask
bigger questions that are important for
forensics
the results and information that we
gather from the data sets today
may be slightly different from that
information and results that may be
generated in the future
using newer techniques
we continue to update our analytical
approaches
and increase the power of this data set
adding new samples to it
each time we sequence new samples and
use those updated analytical approaches
as we move forward there needs to be
strenuous validation of the microbial
based biomarkers identified from this
foundational work
once the performance accuracy and error
of these microbial markers have been
rigorously validated
it may help to identify questions that
are important during death investigation
such as how long has an individual been
dead where did they die
and perhaps what is their cause and or
manner of death
additionally public health is in the
forefront of everybody's mind right now
and the postmortem microbiome provides a
unique opportunity
to screen individuals that may not have
otherwise had access to health care
to detect if antibiotic resistance genes
are spreading in unsuspecting
populations
or perhaps to trace the spread and
prevalence of a disease outbreak or
pandemic
there is also a lot of private sector
interest for how the postmortem
microbiome can be used
specifically interest in how to create
useful and user-friendly assays or
algorithms
to provide reliable information
pertaining to death investigation
and finally as we continue to expand our
knowledge of the postmortem microbiome
we need to think beyond adult cases most
of the published literature has focused
on adult cases
however we should also consider
overlooked populations
such as pediatric and infants to
identify
if the postmortem microbiome can aid in
the determination of their cause and
manner of death
with that i want to thank you for your
attention and i also want to thank my
extraordinary collaborators and graduate
students who have all put a
tremendous amount of effort into these
projects
i would also like to thank the funding
sources for supporting this type of work
i'm more than happy to take any
questions however if you have additional
questions at a later point
please feel free to send me a message at
my email listed above
it is p e c h a
l j e m s u
dot e d u thank you again for your
attention and i hope you have a great
day